in our class when we talk about
foundations there's always an element of
cost-effectiveness so regarding your
foundation especially when your mission
statement is fighting and tolerance to
fighting injustice do you find it hard
to come with metrics to to evaluate the
effectiveness of any of your program how
do you go about choosing which program
to pursue or expanding or or developing
in each a new program given the limited
financial resources right so one of the
things that the Wiesel foundation has
been doing for decades is convening and
bridging networks in bridging leadership
and in terms of evaluating efficacy
impact it's bringing people together who
might not know each other bring
stakeholders for multiple sides of an
issue from the variety of disciplines so
when we're looking at measuring efficacy
what are the projects that arise from
fostering those relationships and
bringing people together or amplifying
good work so our annual conference of
Nobel laureates brings together
laureates but many other heads of state
and various stakeholders what we're
trying to do is create start the process
of building those networks and hope that
we're bringing the right people to the
table in areas that we're able to
measure that efficacy and others are as
well what do you think I mean I agree
with you and I think especially with a
mission such as such a broad like
mission statement not broad but like
fighting justice is a really broad topic
I feel like there's always an element of
trust so bridging leadership is really
important so and one example is just
exploring his ideas one thing that we've
been trying to do for decades is look at
college students people your age what
are the ethical issues that are
important to you and what can we do to
amplify some of those questions and
issues I mean your university press a
couple of months ago published a book of
the collect
essays of college students around the
country who are dealing and pack trying
to tackle ethical issues it's one of the
ways the foundation is trying to support
the inquiry and I hope it helps and now
with internet there's even more that we
could be doing